Joe Biden informs 40 million black
Americans that if they support our
president
they ain't black is Joe Biden a racist
is Joe Biden rapists democratic
representative Ilhan Omar says she
believes the woman accusing Biden of
sexual assault but she's going to vote
for Biden anyway and president Trump
accuses MSNBC's Joe Scarborough
of murdering a staffer some heavy stuff
to start the week I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right you all heard the clip is Joe
Biden a racist does the word racist even
mean anything after 50 years of being
totally abused by the political left
what is it I want to know let me know in
the comments section if you think that
crazy old Uncle Joe is a racist we will
play the clip for you and then we will
play all of the many many excuses that
the left is making for Joe because you
know of course they are joe by knees on
this show with the radio character
Charlamagne tha God and the interview is
actually going fairly well and then joe
biden made this now infamous statement
that if you do not know if you're gonna
vote for Trump or for Joe Biden then you
ain't black
I joined if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're from eard
Trump and you ain't black so listen to
what he's saying it what you saying is
actually a little bit more radical even
than what some people are suggesting
he's not saying that if you're a
Republican and you're black then you
ain't black he's not saying that if
you're not gonna vote for me then you
ain't black it's actually even further
than that what he's saying is if you
even have the slightest question as to
whether or not you're gonna vote for me
if it if it even enters into your mind
that it would be possible to vote for a
Republican then you ain't black in order
to be authentically black according to
Joe Biden you have to be unconsciously
democratic unconsciously left-wing
obviously that is absurd the the
craziest image of all the most absurd
image of all is that Joe Biden one of
the whitest people that has ever walked
the face of the earth is now telling
someone like Kanye West that he is not
black telling someone like Tim Scott
that he is not black telling someone
like Allen West that he's now black
right the list goes on and on the left
immediately started making excuses for
him close your eyes imagine what the
headlines would look like if a
Republican had made a similar statement
could you imagine
right it would be wall-to-wall coverage
outrageous he has to resign this guess
is like David Duke is running for
president right that's so that's what
you were deferred but because it was Joe
Biden because it was a Democrat here the
headline CNN what Biden said was
outrageous but some say so was the
reaction some say that a who is some is
some is some the nickname of John Blake
CNN writer
it's that that seems to me very likely
or not even John Blake the writer but
whoever the editor is that wrote that
headline this is something that the left
always does when they get a bad series
of headlines and they want to counter
that narrative they say okay here's the
headline yeah that's really bad but some
say it's not that bad and then the some
who say it or always just the left-wing
journalists who are writing writing the
headlines
so that's CNN you get from Vox do Joe
Biden's you ain't black comments
ultimately matter no no of course not if
Joe were a Republican they would matter
a whole lot but now do they matter know
that now this is the Clinton strategy
the Vox the Vox headline is what you
would always see from the Clintons which
is that the Clintons would have some
scandal and then they would just
immediately tamp it down say this is old
news we mean it's old news this scandal
happened yesterday now it's old news it
happened yesterday
today's today it's not a big deal move
on the organization move on org the very
prominent left-wing organization was
founded to to get the Clintons through
the impeachment and they said well look
we got to move on this is old news no
big deal doesn't matter nothing to see
here folks that's what voxcom did and
then my favorite one came from the most
ridiculous of all of those newspapers
The Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness this headline on an article by
Jonathan Capehart come on
Biden's you ain't black comment was
clearly a joke
what was the joke I saw some people on
social media try to say this
Joe Biden was joking and so therefore
it's not an offensive comment what's the
joke all right look I'm I'm perfectly
willing to give people grace if they're
telling jokes what is the joke that
black people have to vote for Democrats
is that I guess that's the dance what
he's saying the joke is black people
can't think for themselves the joke is
black people need to vote the way that
this white man tells them to vote that
ha ha isn't that the joke huh look it's
clear yeah yeah I know
I if that's the joke I get the joke but
that's what is offensive so it's not a
joke I mean a joke requires a setup and
a punch line a joke requires some humor
that's not what Joe Biden was saying Joe
Biden's point was was pretty blunt which
is that if you are black you must vote
for Democrats and if you don't vote for
a Democrat you lose your blackness that
then this is the kind of ideological
point that they come to somehow there is
a difference between being racially
black and being politically black and
the one that actually matters more is
whether you are politically black
regardless of your skin color this is
the precise point that was made by a New
York Times writer not just any New York
Times writer a woman who just won the
Pulitzer Prize for that
16:19 project that completely anti
historical trash that the New York Times
is using to try to rewrite American
history this woman's name is Hannah
Jones and she said basically just what I
just said she said quote there is a
difference between being politically
black and being racially black I am NOT
defending anyone but we all know this
and should stop pretending that we don't
so she is defending him and it is a
repulsive comment what she's saying this
is what ideologies do this you know I
tried I tried not to be too ideological
on the show I have a point of view I
have a vision of the world but I try not
to be ideological and the difference is
this.what ideologue do is they
prioritize their ideas over reality so
when reality comes to country
their ideas they they don't deny their
ideas they deny the reality this is
something you would hear as a kind of
joke about ideologue they'll say who
cares if it works in practice doesn't
work in theory right it's all about
prioritizing ideas of a reality when the
to conflict they go with their own
theories and this is where we see
identity politics really delve into the
realm of the absurd the idea here is
that if you are say Tim Scott right a
Republican black senator you are not
really black if you're Clarence Thomas
right you're a conservative black jurist
you're not really black I mean sure your
skin is black but blackness is something
deeper than skin color it is according
to the left a political ideology and so
so Bill Clinton right very much a white
guy is the first black president in
certain colloquial understandings Sarah
Palin is not a woman I once read kid you
not I read a gender studies paper a
published academic Gender Studies paper
that denied that Sarah Palin is a woman
because of her ideology because her
ideology is conservative or her I guess
her philosophy is conservative or her
lack of ideologies her ideology right
Rick Rennell he's the acting DNI he's a
homosexual but he's not really a
homosexual you see according to the left
he can't possibly really be a homosexual
because he is more conservative he's not
a leftist for the let for the left black
is not a race it is an ideology one
woman is not a sex it's an ideology gay
is not a sexual preference it is an
ideology so leftist men can attack
Phyllis Schlafly right they can attack
an Coulter that's fine it's actually
feminist to physically attack those
women because they're not really women
and if you attack them then you're
actually the real feminist and Kanye
isn't really black according to this
ridiculous idea you know a lot of people
came in and defended Joe Biden even more
is it an effective strategy is Joe Biden
really a racist we'll get to that in a
second first though I've got to thank
our friends over at Bureau you know it
can be very frustrating when your Wi-Fi
is being slow and taking forever to load
and maybe you've noticed that with a lot
of people using the Wi-Fi these days
that tends to happen well I've got a
solution for you
zero is Wi-Fi that your home deserves
if blankets your whole home with fast
reliable Wi-Fi not just inside but
outside to zero it's it's an amazing
product it extends your Wi-Fi so that
you can enjoy it the nicer weather and
get work done from your deck gyro
eliminates poor coverage dead spots and
buffering you'll have a consistently
strong signal wherever you need it
you're right this is my favorite part by
the way gyro sets up in minutes even I
can do it if I can do it I promise you
can do it plugs right into your modem or
modem router box and you manage it from
a dead simple app that lets you pause
the Wi-Fi for dinner and gets alerts if
any device attempts to join your network
it's just fabulous right now you get a
twenty twenty percent off an arrow pro
mesh Wi-Fi system I love it I love how
easy it is to set up most of all you can
get your Wi-Fi fixed as soon as tomorrow
go to eurocom slash Knowles
enter code Knowles canna wles a checkout
get your free next day shipping with
your order EER Oh calm slash Knowles
code Knowles at checkout to get your
arrow delivered with free next day
shipping but you got to use this URL to
receive this offer euro dot-com slash
Knowles code Knowles so I don't know if
you remember Sheila jackson-lee
she is a Democratic congresswoman not
one of the most impressive members of
the House of Representative but
certainly one of the most entertaining
and Sheila jackson-lee is a black woman
and she rushed to Joe Joe Biden's
defense I don't believe anyone who saw
that exchange would in any way suggest
that anyone is blacker blackest or less
black that exchange was ingest but on
second thoughts it could have been
spoken differently
but I think african-americans are truly
one of the most astute political groups
in this nation and they know what it's
best for them their children their
families their elders and as relates to
the generational divide if you will or
the unity of such those who are
Millennials are clearly a suit and what
I would say to you is that that was not
what the vice president said in terms of
those words what what I would say to you
is that is not what the vice president
said using those words what I would say
to you is the words that you heard Joe
Biden say those are not the words that
he actually said I think they are I'm
pretty sure we have the video and you
can replay it and that's what he said
she ends this really rambling incoherent
non argument at the very end with the
point that she made at the beginning
which is don't believe your lying ears
he didn't really say that she opens up
she is I don't think anybody was talking
about how someone is more black or less
black or not black that's exactly what
they were does exactly what Joe Biden
was talking about and what he said and
we have the tape and he used those exact
words but her strategy probably a smart
strategy here is just deny it then say a
bunch of words that don't have any
meaning next to one another and then
move on all right that's the that's the
voxcom strategy it's the Clinton
strategy that's what Democrats do all
the time and it's an effective strategy
this whole thing is an effective
strategy you know the the line itself
only occurred to Joe Biden because black
Americans vote overwhelmingly for
Democrats so it's a sort of polite joke
among the left right if you don't vote
for Democrats you're not really black
we're gonna rescind your black card
identity politics has worked very well
it's a very very strong motivator it has
forged this reliable political voting
bloc it's not as though black people
always voted for Democrats not as though
they always voted for Republicans before
that there was a time at which the black
vote was was a little more divvied up
now
it's pretty solidly democratic because
identity politics is pretty strong if
you are told what Joe Biden is telling
them which is that not only will you
lose a policy or two if you don't vote
with me but you will lose your very
identity then that's a pretty strong
motivator to vote a certain way and this
comes alongside a long history of Joe
Biden's stupid and offensive comments on
race marched in the civil rights
movement I marched with tens of
thousands of others he had not actually
marks during the civil rights movement
and kept telling the story and I came
out of the civil rights movement I was
one of those guys that sat in and marks
and all that stuff
his aides went back to say look he was
in office marching for the idea that's
time to work I was not out marching
you're gonna put y'all back in Chains
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talons white kids what of all of the
Biden comments Elizabeth I think the one
that hits you the most is hey look black
kids are poor kids are just as talented
as white kids what you're you are
conflating a few things there so is Joe
Biden a racist what does that even mean
anymore what does the word racist mean
after the left has used it as just a
synonym for people who disagree with us
it's just a synonym for bad is just a
synonym for not a leftist does Joe Biden
hate black people no I don't think he
hates black people just Joe Biden make
offensive comments about black people
yes he regularly makes offensive
comments about black people when do you
remember when Obama ran the first time
he said aw
the first articulate clean good-looking
black candidate that's a that's a fairy
tale man that's that's almost verbatim
what he said you know he he makes these
offensive comments a lot does Joe Biden
take the black vote for granted yes does
that make him a racist I'll leave you to
decide because the word has become very
ambiguous here's what we do know the
left has spent the last eternity
smearing everybody to the right of
Hillary Clinton
as a bigot okay and so I'm less
interested in the Joe Biden story per se
I'm more interested in how we react to
it because the minute that the right
does anything even close to the same
accuses our opponents of some kind of
bigotry with a lot more evidence by the
way we're told that's out of bounds only
the left is allowed to do that not the
right the right has to shut up and take
it time and time again the left is
allowed to fight with every single
available tactic and the right is
supposed to tie one hand behind our back
at least and Trump is rightly sick of
this so now Donald Trump is just coming
out swinging he's encouraging claims
that people are racists rapists and even
murderers should the right take the
gloves off I think the right absolutely
should we got to be careful not to go
too far there was a big attack that
Trump leveled over the weekend I think
it's not necessarily in in the totally
right direction but it's pretty funny
because it's gonna make Joe Biden sweat
we'll get to that in one second though
first I got to get to our friends it
keeps you know I do not want to go bold
I don't it's not that everyone looks bad
bald but me I think I would not look
great I derive at least 80% of my power
from my hair and my little peanut head
would not look particularly good with
that hair two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 the best
way to prevent hair loss do you know
what it is do something about it will
you still have hair left you used to
have to go to the doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription now you
don't thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
they make it very easy and they deliver
your medication every three months so
you can say goodbye to pharmacy checkout
lines and awkward doctor visits but the
key here is prevention all right you can
prevent this sort of thing but you got
to take steps now because the treatments
can take up to four to six months or
more to see results you got to act fast
if you're ready to take action prevent
hair loss go to keep stuck on slash
Knowles to receive your first month of
treatment for three that is ke EPS comm
slash Knowles canna wles
so I think the right should take the
gloves off here absolutely but we got to
be careful not to make unforced error
and hurt ourselves president Trump
leveled this attack at Joe Biden over
the weekend mass incarceration has put
hundreds of thousands behind bars for
minor offenses Joe Biden wrote those
laws that's come out of this Congress
has had the name Joe Biden on that bill
we do everything but hang people for
jaywalking in this bill Joe Biden's
policies destroyed millions of black
lives Joe Biden may not remember but we
do so conservatives are against putting
criminals in jail now is that the idea
ah I don't like this ad I mean it's in a
way a devastating ad right even down to
the very last part where the ad says Joe
Biden may not remember but we do Joe
Biden doesn't remember what he had for
breakfast this morning but the point of
the ad do we agree with that now we it's
very conservative now to not throw
criminals in prison I don't think that's
conservative I I think actually we
should put more criminals in prison I
think we have too many criminals on the
street and that's what most
conservatives thought until it was
politically convenient to attack Joe
Biden not not a great way to attack him
I don't think if it works tactically
fine I understand there are tactical
considerations here but I think it's
gonna hurt us in the long term okay we
we got to be careful not to when we're
leveling these attacks I'm taking the
gloves off
let them come back and swing around and
hit us again we got to make sure that
these attacks are clean and they don't
back us into a corner the left is really
good at this
the left is really good and not
necessarily taking a stand that what the
left does is it just criticizes right it
deconstructs you always hear these kind
of terms in the left-wing academy
deconstruction criticism critical theory
you just attack your opponent without
taking a stand yourself what I don't
like about this ad is it backs us into
this corner of saying we basically want
to spring criminals from the clink I
don't want to spring criminals from the
Clank I want to attack Joe Biden but I
don't want to put myself in a corner
where I have to defend something that I
I can't defend a good example of a
of a solid wild crazy attack with the
gloves off that doesn't back you into a
corner is actually another one that
Trump lodged over the weekend this is
one of his wildest attacks ever and it
was against Joe Scarborough over at
MSNBC President Trump
tweets out this comment about Joe
Scarborough this was in response to a
tweet that said Trump calls for
investigation into Joe Scarborough for
the murder of a staffer in 2001 more on
that in a moment
Trump tweets out quote a blow to her
head body found under his desk left
Congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida and he's a nut job
with bad ratings keep digging
use forensic geniuses you madman you are
accusing your political opponent of
murder but it's a pretty clean attack
actually I'm not I'm not saying I'm I'm
defending the attack per se but I'm
defending the tactic here because Joe
Scarborough everyday goes out on
television even to the three people who
watch it and accuses Trump of all sorts
of crazy things and so now Trump is
swinging back and saying oh yeah there's
some letter open questions about how you
maybe murdered that staffer I'm not
saying that there's evidence that he
murdered the staffer here's the story
may 2001 this is five months into Joe
scrubbers fourth term in Congress he
announces all of a sudden that he's
gonna resign and he says he wants to
spend more time with his kids it's kind
of a strange excuse you hear this a lot
from politicians who are in scandals
because if he wanted to spend more time
with his kids presumably he would have
thought about that five months earlier
and just not run for a fourth term then
a couple months later July 20th 2001 one
of joe scarborough's aides lori klaus
utas was found dead from a head injury
in joe scarborough's office in Fort
Walton Beach Florida then this is
according to Joe Scarborough at the time
allegations spread all over the Internet
that he was involved even though it
looked as though it was an accident
I do want to be clear there is no
evidence that Joe Scarborough murdered
staffer there were rumors at the time
that they were having an affair all
sorts of stuff I mean this is according
to Joe Scarborough himself and Joe
Scarborough even joked about this on
another MSNBC show hosted by the shock
jock Don Imus you know occasionally
we're gonna try to help you and you're
just right Charles you've got to listen
tell me what I need well no you're doing
great I mean don't be afraid to be funny
okay
because you are funny that was something
you know I asked you why you wanted
Congress you said you did sexually the
intern then you had to kill her that's
pretty risky to say what are you gonna
do so you could be give me you can be
very good i mean i'm i actually like
keith olbermann and I like Matthews and
they're great could work out for you
what's gonna be a good lineup I'd and
the guys at NBC and women NBC looks like
they're gonna stick with us okay so he
jokes about it here's my take do I think
Joe Joe Scarborough murdered his staffer
I think I think the idea that Joe
Scarborough murdered his staffer is at
least as plausible as the idea that
Donald Trump has secretly been a sleeper
cell Manchurian Candidate for Moscow all
along all these last 4050 years that
we've known who he is
here's my take I think that the idea
that Joe Scarborough is a murderer is at
least as plausible is the idea that
Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist here's what
I think what's good for the goose is
good for the gander
and if the left is going to reshape our
politics to now primarily base itself on
insane ridiculous preposterous radical
personal accusations against people then
you know I guess it sure would be a
shame if some of those accusations flew
back on the Left wouldn't it here's my
take I mean what what Trump is doing
here even though he's talking about a
very serious issue is actually engaging
in a little bit of levity in politics
right because the left is saying with a
straight face
he's a Manchurian Candidate for Moscow
Breck
Cavanaugh's a rapist and they say that's
very seriously and what Donald Trump
does is he goes he goes oh yeah hey you
guys think Joe Scarborough is a murderer
I don't know I'm not saying anything
it's just a little what you think he
might be a murderer he's actually sort
of telling a kind of political joke and
then the joke is getting these
self-serious leftists to go even more
apoplectic I think that levity is OK in
a time where people are way too self
serious in politics and where where one
side gets to level outrageous
accusations but then the minute the
other side does anything even remotely
resembling that it's a national disgrace
okay and I also think that there is
nothing virtuous about one side of the
political aisle completely unilaterally
disarming I don't think there's any
avert anything virtuous about the left
being able to use a whole host of
tactics and the right having to tie
their hands behind their backs and I in
particular don't think that's virtuous
because the left he is not virtuous the
left is vice it is vice mobilized in
politics and the right for all its many
flaws is actually attempting a sort of
politics of virtue and so I don't think
it's good for the right to be
handicapped and for the left to be able
to do whatever they want there's nothing
good about that
and I'm glad that the right is fighting
back but I want the right to fight back
smart I don't want the right to fight
back in a way that's gonna hurt us in
the long run the you you can't expect
the left to play nice or fair or even
stick to its own rules it's not going to
happen a great example of this sort of
tangentially related to Joe Biden comes
from Ilhan Omar Ilhan Omar part of the
squad being a radical leftist freshman
congresswoman Ilhan Omar actually
acknowledged that she believes the woman
accusing Joe Biden of rape and yet she's
gonna vote for Joe Biden anyway we'll
get to that in one second first I got to
thank our friends over at Rock Auto you
know when you go to the auto parts store
they never actually have what you want
right they never have what you need
they're just too many parts out there
brick and mortar doesn't have it so what
do they do they go online they probably
go to rockauto.com they
order the part they charge you twice as
much rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years which is basically the whole
history of online go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts doesn't make sense even I
don't know anything about cars even I
know that's a crazy idea head on over
there it's so easy to navigate that
website go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck then most importantly right Knolls
Canada wles in there how did you hear
about us box so that they will know that
we sent you that as rockauto.com head
over there right now right Knowles in
there how did you hear about us box so
allegations that Joe Biden is a racist
allegations that Joe Biden is a rapist
some people believe the allegations
including Ilhan Omar who told The Sunday
Times of London quote I do believe read
justice can be delayed but should never
be denied and then do you know what she
said she said believing survivors is
consistent with my values yes i endorsed
against Biden and I didn't pick him as
our nominee with that said in this
interview I did on May 6th we talked
about that and quotes aren't all aren't
always in context I will vote for him
and help him defeat Trump two things at
the same time I do believe Reid
I do think Joe Biden is a rapist that's
what that means I think Joe Biden
sexually assaulted that woman and I will
vote for him that's the level of
partisan commitment we're talking about
that's that's what you owe Biden's
talking about when he says if you are
even slightly questioning whether you're
gonna vote for me you're not black
that's how deep this identity goes that
Ilhan omar would vote for someone she
believes to be a rapist because of how
deep that identity goes you are not
nearly
going to crack that kind of insane
identity politics with slightly better
arguments or slightly better fine-tuned
policy prescriptions about entitlement
reform that ain't gonna work okay the
way that you're going to crack it is by
using all of the tools available to you
that includes cultural tools that
includes the mass media that includes
certain policy arguments that includes
shaking things up okay the the old
strategy of getting that perfectly
precise totally pure tie one arm behind
your back kind of politics that that is
not gonna wear that has failed and that
is going to continue to fail on its
gonna make problems worse you've got to
get creative guy like Trump is is a
change agent he is an agent of chaos and
politics and so with all that creativity
and chaos we've just got to make sure
that we set ourselves up well in the
long term you got to win short-term
victories too because if you lose too
many short-term victories there isn't
any long term to think about speaking of
consent we will get to a wild story out
of a local news channel that brings up a
lot of these questions about sex and
rape culture and and modern love but
first I've got to thank you and I've got
to share some very good news you
remember we had a few weeks ago we had
the double tumblr promo so you sign up
for daily wire you didn't just get one
left is tears tumblr which is essential
but you got a second do I have I do have
a second you got a second leftist years
tumblr these days becoming more and more
important well I got good news the
double tumblr is back but it's only
available for our most exclusive
membership to your all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership you get everything
right you get more of Ben's show you get
Q&A is you get exclusive editorial
articles yet an ad-free website
experience could it get any better yes
it can you get two tumblers very
important daily wire calm slash to
subscribe go there right now join all
access get 15% off with coupon code
Knowles canna wles what is it daily wire
calm / subscribe coupon code Knowles
safe
percent and allow me to save you from
drowning head on over to daily we're
back on we'll be right back with a lot
more
so there was a crazy crazy story over
the weekend and it tied in with this
this kind of consent that we're all
talking about I mean things just think
about the Tara Reid story I think about
how crazy this is
you've got a woman who is who was on Joe
Biden's staff who is certainly much more
credibly accusing Joe Biden than anybody
accused Brett Kavanaugh and you've got
some people like Yellen Omar saying yeah
I believe her but I don't care that is a
keen level of partisanship you now have
the mainstream media this is a piece in
The Associated Press trying to figure
out how do we how do we finesse the
Ilhan Omar angle how do we say yeah we
believe her because we have to believe
all women because that was the position
we backed ourselves into but also we
want to keep voting for Joe Biden the
way they're going to do that it's
actually pretty brilliant
is now being shown in the pages of The
Associated Press what they're going to
do now is imply that this woman is a
victim imply that she's a little bit
crazy and then conclude that she's not a
victim of Joe Biden but she's still a
victim so we can feel sorry for her and
take her seriously that's what they're
doing now they said quote Biden accusers
life marred by abuse and financial
hardship one thing is clear in the
complicated sometimes contradictory and
often Kaye had a chaotic story of terror
read her life has not been easy Wow
see what they sandwiched in there it's
complicated
and it's chaotic and then right in the
middle sometimes contradictory so they
don't believe her they don't believe her
but they want you to know that they take
her really seriously even though her
central claim they don't believe because
it's contradictory they don't like her
but her life's not that easy she's a
victim her earliest childhood memory was
being abused by her father she told her
former husband a man she would later
leave after saying he abused her too
okay so she got this abuse but now we're
seeing a pattern right they're starting
they're starting to quest
in this pattern she was also a child of
big dreams of being an Olympic skier and
studying acting at Juilliard
before developing an interest in
politics she was hired in 1992 for a
low-level staff job for one of the
nation's highest profile senators at the
time Joe Biden less than a year later
Reid said she was again the victim of
abuse assaulted by bide in the hallway
of a Senate office building an
allegation he vehemently denies so is
the is it real or is this fake stories
not that what the story is suggesting is
she's crazy but she's had a tough life
and then finally at the end
inconsistencies in her accounts have
also complicated matters defense
attorneys are now reviewing whether she
may have testified falsely about her
education credentials in multiple
domestic violence cases
the Monterey County weekly and the New
York Times first reported let's be very
clear here
there are many fewer inconsistencies in
Tara Reid's account than there were in
Christine Blasi Ford's account christine
Blasi Ford couldn't help but contradict
herself she contradicted herself on when
the alleged assault by Brett Kavanaugh
happened where it happened who was at
the party where it happened she
contradicted herself about why she
installed a door in her home which she
said was related to the alleged assault
though there was no evidence that ever
happened she contradicted herself about
her fear of flying she contradicted
herself about everything we don't even
know if this woman met Brett Kavanaugh
and yet you never saw any articles about
the inconsistencies in her story you're
hearing them now about Tara Reid because
they they don't want to deal with this
issue they've backed themselves into a
corner here and this this does tie into
it in a way an unrelated story but the
underlying sexual politics is still
there this story out of a local news
channel a girl's being interviewed about
coronavirus and why she doesn't wear a
mask when she's at at the park and then
out of the blue some guy walks up and
kisses her and the guy finishes kissing
her and she's got butterflies you know
she's she's like really enjoyed this
kiss and it's a funny little news story
and the news plays it all well and good
right wrong I feel as if masts are not
% important I feel as if if I
interrupted a spontaneous kiss from
someone that she doesn't know having met
just minutes earlier
Gillian McGowan says she's ok with the
kiss we asked Jack ring the man who
initiated the kiss if he's aware of all
the risks of kissing a person you don't
know during a pandemic you worry about
possibly either of you having that
passing minute oh not as I just said it
right now but yeah I probably do right
now I think is worth it what a great
story
what a great amid all this stupid
political news on a great story which is
I guess these two had met when they were
walking their dog has probably flirted a
little bit then she's being interviewed
on camera and this guy thinks it would
be kind of funny and flirtatious to walk
up and while she's on camera give her a
kiss and then it's this great moment
when he pulls away she looks like she is
just floating on a cloud she's sad she's
giggling about it right a friend of mine
tweeted out this video she said a woman
needs a man like a fish needs up and
then just that clip right that's the
it's the old line from the feminist sing
Gloria Steinem women don't mean need men
and then you fast forward to this and
this woman's like gaga over this guy
kissing her right so whatever a sweet
story she walks away she goes texted me
that was fun right do you know that we
now live in such a clinical sterile
humorless culture that the news channel
that aired that segment a segment that
was so charming I thought it was fake
and staged they ended up having to
apologize because according to this news
channel what they just aired was
basically tantamount to rape a follow up
on a story that aired last night on CTV
News at 11:30 in a story on social
distancing we included an interview with
a woman in a park during the interview a
stranger came up to the woman and kissed
her directly on the lips our story then
focused on the dangers of
kissing a stranger on the lips during
the pandemic it was wrong to air this
video the video demonstrated
non-consensual behavior and downplayed
the fact that what occurred was simply
unacceptable and offensive it does not
meet CTV News editorial standards and we
apologize oh my gosh this is exactly
what we were talking about at the top of
the show this is this is exactly what
we're talking about on the racist rapist
all the kind of hysterical claims this
is what ideologue do they have their
ideas and then there's reality and when
their ideas contradict reality the ideas
have to win the ideas have to clobber
reality would anybody look at that video
would anybody look at that interview and
say that guy raped that girl the guy who
kissed the girl on camera he raped her
no least of all the woman the woman was
the one who said text me thanks for that
kiss it ties in you know there's a
statistic that goes around college
campuses that one in five or even one in
four some say women are raped on college
campus meaning that Harvard Yard is more
dangerous for women than downtown
Fallujah right that obviously isn't true
one of the places that that number comes
from is a survey that was sent out it
was conducted by activist feminists to
get ascertain what happened in people's
sexual lives and concluded that one in
five or one in four women on college
campuses have been raped even though the
women themselves did not think that they
were raped so the women who this
actually happened to disputed the
ideologue interpretation of their
situation but the ideologue always have
to win likewise consider the other side
of this if Joe Biden actually did what
he's being accused of I'm not saying he
is I don't know that I believe this
woman but Ilhan Omar says she does
believe this woman and what this woman
said is that Joe Biden's sexually
assaulted her even according to that
description Joe Biden can't really be a
rapist and therefore
Ilhan Omar could endorse him for
president because Joe Biden is a
Democrat and yet look Democrats just
don't do that sort of thing left wingers
look that's the sort of thing that
milquetoast federal judges like Brett
Kavanaugh do but not good Democrats like
Joe Biden same thing with the racism did
Joe Biden do a racism did he make a
racist comment on that show where he
said if you don't know if you're gonna
vote for me then you ain't black I guess
but you know certainly by the left
standards that would be considered
racist but it can't be racist if Joe
Biden does it because he is a Democrat
if you're a black person and you vote
for Donald Trump are you still a black
person yes of course in reality that's
true but not according to the ideology
and for the left when the ideologies and
the reality come into conflict the
ideology has got to win I mean consider
consider that famous photograph from
World War two you know at VJ Day victory
over Japan day when the sailor comes
back and they're in Times Square and he
dips that nurse and they're kissing this
is one of the classic photographs ever
taken
so embodies the spirit of the country
and for at least 60 years after it's
probably set 65 years after that photo
was taken it was considered this
wonderful moment of relief of love of
victory right but then starting about 10
years ago people started to reinterpret
that image and say that was an image of
a rape of sexual assault seriously
that's that's how this is discussed
among the left would anybody look at the
image of the sailor kissing the nurse
and say that's rape no of course not but
according to the ideology it is and so
they have to deny the physical reality
and go with the ideology you see this
not just in the realm of our sex
politics you see this even when it comes
to something like coronavirus New York
Times publishes a incredibly demagogic
emotionally manipulative piece over the
weekend but you know hey that's the New
York Times this is an editorial it's
it's I mean I guess it's a technically a
news story really it's an editorial that
was signed by the
New York Times called an incalculable
loss talking about the victims of
coronavirus America is fast approaching
a grim milestone in the corona virus
outbreak each figure here represents one
of the nearly 100,000 lives lost so far
but account only reveals so much
memories gathered from obituaries across
the country help us to reckon with what
was lost so just from the very beginning
the headline is not true right because
what the headline is saying is that the
loss is incalculable and then they
immediately give you the calculation
they say it's about a hundred thousand
people and then they list all of these
people in the article so it is
calculable now I guess the point they
would say is well you can't possibly
calculate the value of a human life yeah
of course I certainly agree with that
but then then no calculation involving
anything in the social science this is
possibly useful right because I guess
the only calculations that you could
then really calculate would be purely
abstract ones like mathematics but the
minute you bring a human being into it
then it's incalculable according to the
New York Times or its calculable and
they're just being demagogues sure you
can say well there's no way to quantify
a human life yeah I agree but we still
have statistics right we still have
death statistics crime statistics health
statistics so we do calculate them in
some way but they're trying to prime you
up for this emotional manipulation then
they just start listing people right so
they'll say auditor and Silicon Valley
Patricia dad 57 they'll say a little bit
about her great grandmother with an easy
laugh Marion Krueger 85 Kirkland
Washington it's really sad right you're
just talking about people who who died
and you see all the various people there
then you get to the sixth name on the
list just number six
Jordan driver Haines twenty-seven of
Cedar Rapids Iowa say 27 not a lot of 27
year olds died from coronavirus do a
little quick little google search turns
out he didn't die from coronavirus he
was murdered but now in our kind of
quirky calculations of this virus where
the numbers keep changing sometimes they
go down sometimes they go up sometimes
the criteria get a little bit different
sometimes thousands of people who
weren't even tested for the virus are
just added to the death roll number
on the New York Times emotional
manipulation list was just murdered it's
just as sad to be murdered but it's not
coronavirus an autopsy has ruled the
death of Jordan Haynes a homicide his
body was found in a vehicle in a wooded
area off of a 380 on March 12 details
regarding the homicide aren't being
released the journalist who I don't know
who put this one together because it's
just signed by the New York Times they
just googled Co vid 19 coronavirus or
something like that and then because in
this guy's obituary it said that his
funeral services were delayed because of
kovat 19 she just added him to the list
how many people is that being done for
how many I mean in one day in New York
they added through I think 3700 people
to the death count who never tested
positive for coronavirus did they die
from coronavirus maybe I don't know but
the people who added their names to the
list don't know either but this is the
trouble we were told according to the
Maine model that that shut down the
entire world that 2.4 million Americans
were gonna die from coronavirus remember
and that that didn't happen good thank
God I'm so pleased that didn't happen
but it wasn't like it was 2.4 there was
2 million or one and a half million or 1
million or 500,000 now the numbers have
been way reduced I think now we're at
about as the New York Times says about a
hundred thousand deaths so even if it's
two hundred thousand deaths even that's
twice as much as we see now which seems
unlikely but still think that's an over
an order of magnitude less than they
initially told us so they've got to
build and build and build they've got to
craft the narrative even when it
contradicts the facts and they will do
this on any issue from race to rape to
murder to pandemics to anything we have
got to fight against that that is an
irrational way to conduct your politics
fine that the solution to that is not
going to be giving the slightly more
honed in arguments oh if we just improve
our argument by two percent then finally
will will win back the culture no we're
fighting a much more difficult
adversary we have got to be creative in
that as well we've got to use all the
tools at our disposal
sometimes that's levity sometimes that's
history
sometimes that's humor sometimes that's
a personal attack sometimes you got to
do that that is what is at our disposal
we've just got to make sure that we
don't back ourselves into a corner even
while we start fighting a lot big lesson
of the Trump era is to free ourselves up
use the tactics at our disposal that's
going to be chaotic that's going to be a
little bit crazy but if the only way
that we're possibly going to win is if
we untether ourselves and start to
engage with the reality of the political
situation because if we don't if we
continue to live in this abstract idea
that we have of politics as it really is
not then frankly we're doing exactly the
same thing that the left does alright
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles's
the Michael Dahl show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]